في الوقت الحالي ،
إنه سباق سيكون هناك تباين أه
لفترة طويلة ، الفيروس ضد
اللقاحات والمعززات وربما المزيد من
التعزيزات ، تمضي الشركة قدمًا
في لقاح محدد من omicron لكن
العلماء يعملون على ما
يمكن أن يكون حلاً أفضل
وعاجلاً  الحاجة إلى لقاح عالمي
لفيروس كورونا ،
إنه مجرد ما يبدو وكأنه
لقاح يغطي الفيروس المنتشر ، نعم ،
ولكن أيضًا المتغيرات المستقبلية التي لم
نرها حتى الآن وربما أنواعًا أخرى من
فيروسات كورونا أيضًا ، وهذا لا يعني فقط استهداف السارس مثل الفيروسات ولكن أيضًا الاستهداف  مثل
الفيروسات أو يستهدف أيضًا فيروسات البرد.
التي
نعلم أنها كعب أخيل
الآن تذكر أن
الفيروسات تتحور طوال الوقت ،
لذا فإن الحيلة تكمن في العثور على جزء مستقر
من الفيروس  نحن جزء لا يتغير حقًا
من متغير إلى آخر ،
ويطلق عليه القاسم المشترك سوندرز
موقعًا محفوظًا ينتج أجسامًا مضادة
لذلك هو أحد المسارات إلى لقاح عالمي ،
لذلك عادةً ما يكون هذا المكان حيث
يرتبط الفيروس
ببروتين معين على  الخلية المضيفة
التي تستهدفها وإذا غيرت هذا
الموقع ، فلن يكون بإمكانها إصابة
أي دليل كبير جاء من شخص
أصيب بالسارس طوال طريق العودة في
عام 2003. ما هو 1047 درهمًا
، والجسم المضاد dh1047
هو جسم مضاد وجدنا من
عدوى cyrus cov1 بعد
17 عامًا في عام 2020 في
خضم التفشي الحالي ، ووجدوا أن
1047 درهمًا
كان أيضًا وقائيًا ضد الطمع الذي
يقي من فيروس لم يكن
موجودًا حتى عندما تم تصنيع هذه الأجسام المضادة
لأول مرة
، لذلك أخذنا هذا الجسم المضاد
كقالب  لنفترض أنه يجب أن يكون هناك موقع
ما شائع بين cyrus kobe 1 و
cyrus cov2 ودعنا نكتشف ذلك بعد
ذلك سنعلم أنه يجب أن يكون
هناك عدد من المقلاة في اللقاح
استراتيجيات لقاح الفيروس التاجي قيد العمل ولكن
على عكس لقاحات mrna التي عرفناها
في الدوق ، فإنهم يعملون على شيء
يسمى لقاح الجسيمات النانوية ،
وهناك مواقع متعددة يمكن
التعرف عليها من خلال الأجسام المضادة ،
فكر في الأمر مثل كرة قدم بها
بروتينات صغيرة عالقة  يشبه السطح
موقعًا رئيسيًا محفوظًا
لبروتين ارتفاع الفيروس حتى الآن في الرئيسيات
، يبدو أن اللقاح
يعمل والآن أصبح لقاحًا مشابهًا طوره
علماء عسكريون بالفعل
في التجارب البشرية المبكرة
ولكنه مثير مثل هذا العلم
الذي سيستغرقه  الوقت والصبر.
فيروسات الأنفلونزا الأخرى ،
نحن نعمل على لقاح ضد فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية
منذ ما يقرب من 30 عامًا هنا في دوق
وفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية هو أحد أسرع
أشكال الحياة تطورًا في جهاز EA
rth لأن فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية يتحور بشكل
أسرع وهذا أحد الأسباب التي تجعل الدكتور بارتون
هاينز يعتقد أن تطوير لقاح عالمي
لفيروسات كورونا قد يكون أسهل ، وقد سمح
تطوير هذا النظام الأساسي لفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية على
مدى السنوات الخمس الماضية بحدوث هذا
عندما نشأت الحاجة بسرعة كبيرة
الجزء الأكثر صعوبة هو  أن
الفيروس دائمًا ما يغير كيف
تتنبأ بما سيحدث في المستقبل حتى
يكون لقاحك فعالًا
ضده وهو لا يتحدث فقط
عن فيروسات كورونا التي تصيب
البشر في الوقت الحالي
ولكن أيضًا عن الفيروسات الجديدة التي لا يزال من الممكن أن
تنتقل من الحيوانات.
لا أعرف حتى الآن هذا
هو نوع اللقاحات التي سنحتاجها
من أجل منع الوباء القادم
الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا سي إن إن